[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was on a bright September day in 2019
that oleg sentsov finally put his feet
back on Ukrainian soil
he was among a group of 35 Ukrainian
political prisoners and soldiers swapped
with 35 Russian detainees
one year earlier the European Parliament
awarded the Ukrainian filmmaker with the
Sakharov Prize for freedom of thought
electronically the most when you project
on usually the last Nearpod year
depending upon down your thoughts
it was here in this penal colony deep
inside the Arctic Circle that oleg
sentsov spent most of his five years
imprisoned in Russia some 2000
kilometers from Moscow oleg sentsov was
arrested in 2014 after protesting like
thousands of Ukrainians against Russia's
annexation of his native Crimea on
Independence Square in Kiev possibly
lives on what National Preserve idle
speed care Geronimo guerilla nope is
nicer southeastern coastal plain opposed
to mats in odorous millions rubber
stopper to America Western [ __ ] about
drugs stylist Callisto dear summers
Roberto a dealer karate for father no
powers Muslim pad reopening finally in
2015 he was sentenced to 20 years in
prison for preparing a terrorist attack
and arms trafficking grinning
sarcastically in court he hummed the
Ukrainian national anthem
[Music]
Amnesty International denounced it as a
show trial his lawyer called it a
mockery of Jim process in September 2018
the once strapping filmmaker appeared
weak and emaciated he was 139 days into
a hunger strike a few days later on the
6th of october oleg sentsov was forced
to end his strike justice or attending
dr. Rajesh persistence to timidly
organism Rajesh has a liberal media
present Raja born piety be a karmic
troop TV shaky start on Liberty pretty
much the brahmana regime at all stop t
we just go out of here he is at least on
a moose bring my toes at the tiniest
mistake now a free man or like sense of
his calling for the liberation of the
remaining political prisoners in Russia
mr. boss unlike those report any visual
metaphor for such a small business they
should be buiishit Anastacia probably on
the periphery Samba started showing all
mobility it inertia in the situation
before time
despite his ordeal oleg sentsov remains
positive about the future as a filmmaker
and as a human rights activist we must
give up a person yoga mantra shares with
processes if you look like forgotten
booms the mighty few times follows
Anita's postable acumen a photographer
if it's a nobleman both oleg sentsov and
the parliament have renewed their calls
for the immediate release of all
political prisoners in Russia and Crimea
[Music]